hello guys and welcome back to jaegerist
in today's video we will be going
through the story of zenitsu agatsuma
from demon slayer zenitsu was not raised
by his parents so he did not have any
proper guidance when he was young
zenitsu fell in love with a girl and
decided to give her money to appeal to
her however the girl ended up running
away with another guy leaving zenitsu
drowning in debt seeing that he was in
financial trouble with debt collectors
jigoro kuwajima paid off the debt for
zenitsu and decided to train him as a
swordsman zenitsu began to refer to
jaguar as gramps and began to train
alongside gramps's other disciple
kaigaku one day when he was draining
zenitsu climbed up a tree out of fear
that he was being trained to death and
as he began to panic a stroke of
lightning hit him causing his hair to
turn blonde zenitsu and kaigaku hated
each other however zenitsu still
respected him as a senior and for his
strong ambition zenitsu wished to fight
alongside kaigaku as equals one day and
developed his own seventh form hinoi
kazuchi nokami final selection arc after
the final selection zenitu is among the
four people who have passed the zenitsum
is seen talking to himself fearing he
will die one day each one receives a
kasugai crow except zenitsu who got a
sparrow all four are told to choose what
ore they want their sword to be made out
of suzumi manchin ark zenitsu was seen
by tantro begging a random girl to marry
him tanjo stops him and excuses the girl
the zenith explains that he must get
married before his next mission because
he might die he asks tantra to protect
him until he gets married tantra asks
him why he became a demon slayer and
zenitsu explains that he got swindled by
a woman and racked up debt an old man
paid off his debt and trained him later
on the two share a rice bowl as they
travel to the south for their next
mission zenitsu and tanjuro arrive at a
large house in the woods tantra smells
an unfamiliar scent and zennitu hears a
strange sound there are two kids nearby
frozen with fear soichi and taruko
tantro shows them zenning to sparrow to
try to calm them the kids tell them
about a monster has taken their brother
inside that house and that they track
the monster here tandro ensures them
that he and zenitsu will rescue their
brother and defeat the monster zentzu
asks about a non-stop sound of a suzumi
strike once the rest finally hear it a
bloody body is thrown out of the house
and lands in front of them the body is
not that of the children's brother
tantra leaves his box with the two
children for protection although zenitsu
refuses to enter the house at first he
forces himself to join tanjiro once
inside tantro tells zenitsu about his
broken bones that haven't fully healed
yet which scares zenitsu even more since
he can't rely much on tantra for
protection the two kids are frightened
by scratching coming from the box and
come inside the house after zenitsu and
tanjuro the house begins to rumble and
dantero and teruko are teleported to a
random room in the house while zenitsu
is left with soichi while searching for
the exit zenitsu and suichi find anosuke
who runs past them a scared zenitsu and
suichi wander through the house when a
demon sneaks up on them a demon corners
the two in a room and zenitsu passes out
from fear as the demon tries to strike
them zenitsu cuts his tongue off while
unconscious zenitsu quickly defeats the
demon zenitsu wakes up with no
recollection of his actions and thanks
suichi for defeating the demon zenitsu
and suichi into a room and the room
rotates throwing them out of a window
once outside they see anosuke run out of
the house anosuke attempts to attack
nezuko who is inside the box but zenit
super attacks her the zenith explains
his great hearing and that he can hear
living things breathing heartbeat and
their blood circulation zenitz who knew
tanjore was traveling with the demon and
tells him nosqt to back off as he is
going to ask tundra himself why he's
traveling with a demon enosuke
continuously attacks any two an attempt
to kill nezuko tantra attacks inose to
stop him and the two begin to fight and
nosuke passes out from tanjoro's
headbutt after burying the dead they
found inside the house a crow sends the
three demon flares to a house for them
to rest in an elderly lady attends to
them while they are there nadikumo mount
an ark zenitsu tantro and enosuke head
to nadagumo mountain for the next
mission they reach their destination at
night they meet a demon slayer laying on
the ground who begs them for help as he
is pulled into the forest by spider
threats out of fear zenitsu refuses to
go into the forest tandro and anasuke
proceed without him zenitsu contemplates
about not joining his friends zenitsu
realizes that tantra took nezuko along
with him and runs in after them to
protect nezuko while running through the
forest zenitsu sees a human head with a
spider's body zenitsu runs away only to
stumble across the demon responsible for
turning these humans into spider slaves
zenitsu is hit by a spider and only has
30 minutes before he also turns into a
spider does anything faints from fear he
begins to fight while unconscious zenith
was a flashback of his teacher who
encouraged and never abandoned him and a
senior disciple who always looked down
on him zenitsu was only able to do the
first form but honed it to perfection
defeating the demon with the thunder
breathing first form thunderclap and
flash rehabilitation training arc he
complains to kyo about the medicine he
has to take tanjiro goto and aoi kanzaki
arrive with the latter scolding zenitsu
for his constant complaining tanjiro and
zenny to reunite the scarred youth
asking his friend if he is all right and
zenny to responding by bitterly
complaining about everything he has been
through since the natagumo mountain
incident tantra asks any two about
inosuke and mirada and the toe-headed
youth tells him that inosuke is right
next to him chandra asks senosuke to
forgive him for not coming back to help
him but is told not to worry about it
dumb founded by anoski's different
sounding voice tanjore was told by
zennitoo about their friend's condition
a badly injured throat after a rundown
of tanjiru zenitu hinosuke and nezuko's
respective conditions the four comrades
take a much deserved rest they are later
visited by murada who explains what
happened to him when he was summoned to
the hashira meeting and chinobu who
tells them that their rehabilitation
training was about to begin zenitsu
muses over his medical treatment and the
condition of the people turned into
spiders he then thinks about shinobu and
her treatment of these individuals
noting that her sound is irregular and
somewhat unsettling he goes on to note
that tantro and donosuke had been taken
by her to undergo the rehabilitation
training it had come back extremely
exhausted and bedraggled causing him to
despair as he was to join the training
the next day the next day zenitsu joins
his friends at the training where aoi
kanzaki explains that there are three
parts a massage to loosen the body
reflex training with kaneo and whole
body training which is essentially tag
with kaneo and herself and he rates
xenitsu takes his friends aside and
chastises them annoyed that they had
been fooling around with girls but had
come back to the room looking so
miserable tantra asks his toe-headed
friend what in the world he is talking
about but the madden tooth tells him to
shut up explaining that this training
involves a lot of physical contact which
essentially translates into being
touched by the girls on a frequent basis
something he sees as pure bliss inosuke
also irritated at this point says that
zenizu doesn't know what he is talking
about stating that he'll die inside when
he loses to someone with a smaller body
only to be mocked by his friend all
three of them then got started with the
training with zenitsu succeeding due to
his love of women but enosuke making
things difficult for everybody due to
his hatred of losing despite the overall
positive performance of his two friends
tandro continues to lose he is soon
joined by his two fellows however
neither of them can best kaneo at the
reflex training or the whole body
training over the next five days the
three continue their efforts to beat her
but none of them succeed causing xenitu
and enosuke to give up tantrum continues
to persevere but is unable to make any
progress continuing to lose for another
10 days having just witnessed tanzro
beat kaneo during his rehabilitation
test zenitsu and enosuke stagger as they
try to learn total concentration
breathing from tanjarot however despite
numerous attempts the two boys were
unable to grasp the concept of the
technique and struggle to master it
during one of tonjro's lessons chernobyl
interrupts to provide guidance and words
of encouragement to both anasky and
zenni too the method she uses to
encourage them include doubting and
noski's ability in order to get him
fired up as well as telling zenitsu
she's personally cheering for him
specifically so he gets excited nine
days pass after her visit and both the
zenith and enosuke have successfully
mastered the breathing technique having
said goodbye to sumi naho and kiyo the
trio arrive at the train station zenitsu
begins to act erratically after
realizing they weren't given any orders
and could have remained at the butterfly
mansion while trying to deflect
zenitsu's assault tentro explains his
reasoning that they needed to leave in
order to find kyogiro and that it would
have been easier to receive orders while
they were in public mugen train arc
dandruff unosca and zenitsu stand in
front of a train inosuke who has no idea
what a train is describes it as the
master of the land and plans to attack
it zenitsu tries to explain it as a
steam engine but tanjoy interjects by
suggesting that it is a guardian spirit
and that they should not attack it
zenizu finally explains that it is a
vehicle that carries people
unsurprisingly enosuke charges headfirst
into the side of the train which causes
a run-in with the police due to the fact
that they have swords and it's also the
fact that enosuke headbutted the train
soon after zenith explains that the
demon's lair corps are not officially
recognized by the government and that
they should conceal the fact that they
carry swords tangier also notes the
train is called the infinite train and
that kyogiro has probably boarded it
already as danny 2 proceeds to buy
tickets for the train as they enter the
train inosuke is his own bush to herself
screaming about being inside the train
and causing a ruckus the zenith asks
about kiyoduro and tanjo describes him
as someone with flashy hair and notes
that he is very close the trio suddenly
hear loud clamors of tasty inside the
train and trace it to kyoduro he is
described as a glutton by xenitu upon
meeting as a demon appears from the
opposite end of the train kyogre notes
that he was unable to sense him he
proceeds to draw his sword and manages
to finish the demon the trio will claim
kyojiro to train them to which he agrees
subsequently kyojiro and the trio fall
asleep on the train within the train
tantro kyojiro zenitsu and nanasuke can
be seen sleeping soundly zenizu dreams
of having a romantic date with nezuko in
a peach orchard it is pitch black inside
zenitsu's subconscious as enmu's minion
stumbles around trying to find his
spiritual core abruptly the sound of
shark blades breaks the silence and
zenitsu appears behind the minion
holding a large pair of shears enraged
at finding a boy inside his subconscious
he says only nezuko is allowed there and
attacks the minion later on a sleeping
zenitsuagatsuma drops in front of nezuko
and manages to not only set naziko free
but also the other passengers around
them in a flash by using
thunderbreathing first form thunderclap
and flash six-fold he declares that
he'll protect nezuko and she looks on in
awe her admiration is quickly dispelled
however as he pops back asleep
mid-sentence and begins to snore both of
them defend three cards of the train
from enmu after the train is stopped and
during the fight between kyogre and
dakaza nezuku falls asleep in the arms
of a sleeping zenith as well after the
sunrise zenitsu gets her into the box to
protect her from the sunlight some time
later zenny to inform tanjore indonesia
of kyogre's heroics in which he'd used
an extensive amount of his techniques to
save passengers when the train derailed
he then asked tantro if an upper rank
really had come and if they were that
strong which the youth confirmed a
tearful tantro expresses his lack of
strength and aid to kyojiro's fight
wondering if he could ever be like him
zenitsu points out that enosuke is also
crying causing him to be headbutted by
the latter entertainment district arc
four months after the passing of kyojiro
and goku the three boys have been
training relentlessly at the butterfly
mansion while occasionally leaving on
individual missions as xensu goes on
solo missions he becomes less of a
whiner since tenganuzui is willing to
give aoi kanzaki up for his mission
tundra demands that he gives her up and
offers to go in her place at that moment
zenitzu and anosuke arrive to help
protect the girls and they offer to go
on the mission as well tanjiro and
nosuke and zenytu accompany the sound to
shira tengen on a mission to yoshiwara
on their way to the site tengen reveals
they're going to investigate the
disappearance of his wives within the
entertainment district once they arrive
at home tengen informs the group to be
on the lookout for someone he could
marry which infuriates any two he
angrily tells tengen to stop screwing
around and to stop using members of the
core as his matchmakers tenkin blows up
and yells that he doesn't need a
matchmaker since he's already married
and that they're searching for his wife
who failed to respond to his letters
zenizu doesn't believe him and tells
tengan to stop telling his fantasies
causing dengan to angrily whack him in
the face with the piles of letters
tantra begins to sift through the
letters noticing the large quantity and
comments that she must be a fast writer
to which cengan clarifies that the large
quantity is due to the fact that he has
three wives after hearing this zenith's
head explodes with rage thinking that
dengun is lying he demands to know how
it is possible to have three wives
tenkin gets angry at his remarks and
punches any two in the stomach knocking
him unconscious as the group finally
arrives tengen uses his charming looks
to try to give away the boys who are
disguised as girls and is successfully
able to give tundra away to the tokito
house tenkin proceeds down the street
with the other two boys in tow with
zenni too seething in anger the fact
that tengen is proudly flaunting his
visuals enosuke and tengen noticed the
courtney coming towards them on the
street and learned that the courtesan
named koei natsu is on her way to agree
to suit her zenitsu notices the
courtesan and angrily yells at dengan
demanding to know if that's his wife as
well earning him a punch in the face
zenitsu fearfully realizes that he is
the only one left with tengen in the
kyogoko house zenitsu calms down after
his emotional performance and begins to
search for hinatsuru due to the fact
that the staff is mourning the manager's
death he's had trouble collecting any
information on her whereabouts the
zenith decides to use his advanced sense
of hearing in order to listen to try to
find any information in doing so he
overhears a girl quietly sobbing and
rushes to find her when he arrives he
discovers the room is destroyed and the
young girl just shoveled in the middle
of it he approaches her but she begins
to sob again causing zenitsu to
frantically try and comfort her as he's
kneeling on the ground zenitsu gets the
chills as he senses something
approaching from behind the corners into
the house wara bohemi glares down to
them and coldly demands to know what
business he has in her room without
turning around zenitsu realizes that the
sound she's giving off is not human and
realizes that she is the demon that the
demon slayers have been searching for
she angrily repeats her question after
zenith who fails to respond and one of
the other girls at the house explains
that she's new to the house zenith
attempts to apologize and explain that
he was checking on the girl but this
angers the demon who rudely calls
zenitsu ugly and creepy leaving him
shocked she looks around to see that the
room is still a mess and pulls the girl
who was crying by the ear causing her to
yell out in pain the girl apologizes for
failing to clean the room but she
continues to harm the girl causing her
to yell out in agony unable to put up
with the abuse the zenith who grabs the
demon by the arm demanding that she let
the girl go she becomes angry and slams
them into the wall rendering him
unconscious she openly voices her
disgust and demands that he never touch
her again and eerily remarks that she
will administer harsh discipline as she
leaves the room she has her doubts about
zenny 2 and realizes that he isn't an
ordinary human and might possibly be a
member of the demon slayers tengan
stealthily arrives at the meeting with
tanjo and ninosuke undetected and
proclaims that zenith will not be
arriving and that he is missing he also
mentions that he might have put the boys
in immediate danger tenkan tells
hinosuke and tandro that they must leave
the district before the upper ranked
demons make their move and announces
that he will be continuing the mission
alone tanjo tries to argue his decision
however dengan quickly leaves as fast as
he arrived over at the kyu goku house
ominsu's husband is seen holding a
kimono in his hand tenkan appears in the
room and puts a kunai to his throat
demanding to know the whereabouts of
zenni too the man quickly reveals that
zenitsu had suddenly disappeared
elsewhere enosuke can be seen cackling
as he discovers a hole leading to a
demon nest he jumps in the hall and once
he arrives he sees multiple people being
held captive within the obi and
discovers zenith knocked out among them
as well as he tries to wake him up the
ob begins to move demanding to know why
nosuke is there it knows gabe begins his
assault against the ob by slicing
sections of it while simultaneously
insulting it the zenny zenith soon wakes
up and quickly attacks the obi as well
the ceiling explodes and breaks down
stopping the fight after tantro and
dengen managed to defeat daki her
brother giutaro emerged from her body
zenitsu and noski flamboyantly announced
their arrival to the fight which
confuses everyone gyotaro and daki get
riled up and reveal that they've eaten
15 and 7 hashira respectively and begin
to attack the demon slayers as daki
attempts to attack tengen and danjour
from behind the zenith burst through the
home within seconds to block the attack
as enosuke follows him on the rooftop
daki finally recognizes zenitsu from the
kyogoku house and he demandingly
commands her to apologize to the girl
whom he had found crying earlier she
mocks his speech by revealing that women
are treated like merchandise within the
district and as the court is in she was
allowed to do as she pleased with all of
the girls since she was the main
breadwinner of the house when she looks
up at zenit2 a third eye appears on
docky's forehead revealing that gyotaro
can see them via her new eye zenitsu and
enosuke can be seen covered in cuts and
wounds as they prepare to battle with
daki the two boys fight ferociously
against the demon but struggle as they
try to evade attacks from dakizobi the
boys realize the donkey is now attacking
them with the blood blades used by
guitar making it impossible for them to
approach her the zenith calls out to
inosuke and explains that in order to
defeat them they just need to make sure
their heads aren't connected instead of
trying to decapitate the two
simultaneously enosuke comically looks
at zenith too amazed and calls him
awesome after seeing the difference in
his personality compared to his usual
demeanor tantra joins the fight and
informs his comrades that they need a
fast attack in order to cut her neck
inosuke realizes that she has slowed
down and decides to go first as then
into agrees with tanjo to protect him
from behind enosuke proceeds to dash
forward using beast breathing while
zenitsu and dangerous use their
breathing forms to protect him from the
yobe daki begins to crack under the
pressure as inosuke closes in on her he
manages to draw both of his blades on
either side of her neck inosuke buries
his heels into the ground as he uses
beast breathing sixth spang to
effectively decapitate docky on a nearby
rooftop donkey can be seen still alive
trying to help her brother but before
she can get to him zenitsu manages to
free himself from the rubble and attacks
her by using his thunder breathing
zenitsu pleads with his blade to cut
through her neck since he was given the
chance to escape the rubble and attack
her while guitar was subdued she
attempts to use her obi to kill zenny 2
at close range but innocent unexpectedly
rushes up revealing that he protected
his heart from being stabbed by
rearranging his organs he also reveals
that poison has no effect on him since
he was raised on the mountains before
proceeding to assist zenitsu and
decapitating daki the three boys led out
a roar as they muster out the strength
to slice through the demon's necks after
the long battle zenni two and enosuke
managed to decapitate daki up on the
rooftop while tanjuro can be seen
decapitating gyotaro simultaneously on
the ground later after tanjore returned
from swordsmith village the zenith
arrived at butterfly mansion and found
out that nezuko cannot walk in the sun
and speak zenitsu screams and says he's
having a heart attack and grabs nezuko
before screaming more about how cute and
absolutely amazing wonderful and
marvelous it is that nezuko is able to
be out in the sun it is then decided
that all demon slayers will go through
hashira training in order to prepare
themselves for the fight against muzan
after finishing one part of the training
tantra was instructed to go to the next
section of the training with the wind to
share astronomy on his way there he
encountered zenny too who had fled from
the intense and brutal tutelage however
sonomy caught up with him threatening
him back into the spartan light
conditions and ultimately knocking him
out tanjuro and zenitsu make their way
to the stone ashore's training ground
there they find dinosaur and the other
demon slayers training under a waterfall
and are greeted by the stone hashira
meditating in a particular way which
resulted in descending to proclaiming
that it's not a training ground but a
hell ground the training was horrendous
and zenitsu kept on complaining about
the freezing waterfall even inosuke who
was working hard ended up drowning while
eating grilled fish together with the
other demon slayers inosuke asserted
that the stonehenge here is the
strongest in their organization zenitsu
on the other hand was still in disbelief
that gyomi was able to move a boulder
across down but was dumbfounded when he
saw the hashera push an even bigger rock
eventually zenitsu and his friends were
able to complete the waterfall in
long-carrying training but they were
still unable to push the boulder away
during the hashera training zenithal
receives word that kagaku has become a
demon and that his master jigoro
committed safiku as atonement the demon
slayers soon received a letter from the
uyashiki estate warning them about
musan's appearance all hasheras
alongside young demon slayers rush
towards the estate but as soon as they
arrive they witness a huge explosion
they soon find out that kagaya blew up
his mansion in order to weaken muzan as
the demon slaves prepare to attack musan
giant doors suddenly appear and slide
open under the demon slayers causing all
of them to plummet into the infinity
castle muzon mocks them for believing
they have him cornered and declares he
will kill them all tonight inside the
infinity castle zenith comes across
kaigaku his former friend zenitsu and
kagaku face off kagaku mocking zenni too
as puny and weak scoffing out his status
as a demon slayer since he is only able
to do one form the zenith retaliates by
mentioning how happy his former superior
seems as the bottom of the upper rank
there's any two questions why he had
turned into a demon but when kagaku
tries to answer the zenitsu cuts him off
and continues he angrily yells that
jigoro had committed sepaku by himself
upon hearing what kagaku has done
someone was meant to assist him in the
act but instead he died agonizing and
alone all because a user of the thunder
breathing became a demon kagaku scoffs
at the news and asks if he is meant to
be sad or repent unapologetically
refusing to care he declares he will
always stick to those who value him he
states he is glad jaguar died a painful
death angered that all his efforts to
please him never led to him being named
his successor and insults him further by
scoffing at the idea of sharing the
successorship with the dirt like xenitsu
zenitsu furiously tells him that if he
was dirt kaigaku was garbage since he
never managed to learn the first form
commenting that jaguar died miserable
because he wasn't lucky enough to have a
true successor kagaku angrily tells him
not to put the likes of himself with him
and unleashes the thunder breathing
fourth form sending lightning at the
demon slayer however zenitsu has already
avoided the attack and slashed the
demon's neck mocking him kagaku is
stunned his opponent has already sliced
him and comments he seems like a
completely different person declaring
everybody has to die eventually and
sanji guru and zenitsu are no exception
kagaku uses the thunder breathing second
form to kill him zenitsu takes notice of
his five simultaneous attacks and
deduces he must have eaten numerous
people already asking if the demon knows
right from wrong kagaku responds that
those who accept him are right and those
who don't are wrong he then uses thunder
breathing fifth form heat lightning
hitting zenit2 and burning him as he
continues to attack zenitsu he asks him
how he is liking his new demon-enhanced
forms as zenitsu falls after being hit
he remembers back to his days training
alongside kaigaku ironically while
zenitsu only managed to do the first
form kagaku was able to do all but the
first form of thunder breathing he knew
kagaku virulently hated them and zenni
to himself also hated kagaku greatly but
despite this he genuinely respected
kagaku for his work ethic and drive and
despite his place as special within
jigoro's students it never satisfied him
apologizing to jigoro and kagaku he
lands on the wall and stops his fall as
the confused kaigaku looks on zenitsu
uses thunderbreathing seventh form and
speeds upwards decapitating kagaku as
the upper ranked demon becomes enraged
as he never saw it coming he curses his
former master for teaching zenitsu
something he never taught him zennancy
replies that shiguro was never such a
person and that he created this form
himself after zenitsube heads kagaku
both start to fall down to their deaths
zenitsu plummets unconsciously as the
disintegrating kagaku grows furious at
his defeat from zenitsu's hands he
comforts himself with the idea that
zenita will die with them when they hit
the ground however yushiro comes to save
zany too while coldly reminding kaigaku
that without friends he will end up with
nothing finally commenting that dying
alone sure is pathetic the zenith
awakens in a land full of red spider
lilies and ceases former master jigoro
across the river the zenith breaks down
in front of him crying and remorse and
regret for not being able to save
kaigaku as being unable to become a
hashira before his death as ents who
struggles with being caught with the
lilies he realizes that jigoro hasn't
said anything to him jigoro breaks his
silence by calling out zenitsu's name
and with tearful eyes he proclaims that
zenitu is his pride and joy in reality
zenitsu is being patched up by yushiro
while being guarded by murata and
another demon slayer murata realizes he
remembers any two and calls out hoping
for his survival leading yushiro to tell
him to shut up yushiro tells anything he
was lucky kagaku was inexperienced with
his demon power had he fought him a year
later he would have ended up dead muradi
yells not to be so negative attracting
demons to their location to yushiro's
charging later while the hashiris battle
against muzan inosuke kanio and senitsu
suddenly pop into view as the seals
placed on their heads gets sliced off by
muzan's attacks they are taken aback at
how quickly he was able to find them but
kiyomi is pleasantly surprised to notice
them all still alive kaneo and zenitsu
hardly put on new seals and attack muzon
with flower breathing and thunder
breathing respectively after tantra woke
up from his dream he saw that sonomy has
been flung into the upper story of its
all building while obani zenitsu and
anosuke are all unconscious in the
rubble muzan launches an attack on
inosuke and manages to ensnare the young
demon slayer suddenly enosuke is saved
by zenitsu who slices through muzon's
arm whip yelling at tanjo to continue
fighting the zennys who tries to bolster
his spirits and tells him not to die so
that nezuko could become human again and
they can go back to the house they used
to live in wasan smacks to him into a
building brynosuke quickly slices up his
whip to prevent further damage zenitsu
notices that he is losing strength and
he would only be able to muster one more
attack with his full power he then
unleashes thunder breathing seventh form
but only produces a shallow cut on muzan
zenitsu remembers his mentor jigoro and
asks him to give him the kick he needs
as inosuke and tanjore continue their
combined onslaught on nuzon with their
respective breathing forms zenitsu
performs another thunderbreathing but is
aggravated by the fact that he is too
slow and nosuke gets knocked back but
tundra was able to continue attacking
muzon with his sun breathing the zenith
takes a blow intended for tanjuro which
allows dandruff to finally defeat muzan
the sun rises on a new day
disintegrating muzan and everyone hears
a sigh of relief crying as their battle
is finally over zenitsu asked the
kokushi tending to him to tell neziko
that he loved her and was brave fighting
to the very end calling her his wife as
others point out he is not married
suddenly a presumably dead tanjore
starts breathing and giul looks on in
shock as the boy takes advantage of the
shira's surprise to attack him as
tanjore follows up with another swipe
that is intercepted by anosuke who yells
at his friend and asks him what he is
doing inosuke stands over him and tries
to remind hundreds that gio is their
ally as any two approaches the scene
supported by kikushi zenitsu looks on in
disbelief at the scene and says that
everyone is tired and unable to continue
fighting asking for tancho to think of
nezuko giu and nosuke and zenitu look on
in shock as nezuku runs forward and hugs
her demonified brother enos gains they
need to rush forward to help nezuko and
try to bring their friends back the
zenith grabs tantra from behind and begs
him to stop hurting nezuko telling him
that she'd become a human again and that
she might die if he continues angered
tanjo lets out a feral howl and sends
out a shock wave that flings anosuke
zenitsu and gyu back as nezuko
desperately clings to her brother she
falls to the ground as tanjo gets on all
fours and releases bone whips similar to
those of muzan from his back she begs
him to keep fighting his newfound
demonic tendencies however he still
swings a whip towards zenny too guillo
intercepts the attack by performing the
water breathing saving zenitsu and the
kukushi propping him up tundra is
eventually injected with the medicine
and turns back into a human three months
after the battle against busan the world
is now free of evil demons and all the
survivors of the battle resolved to
continue living despite all they lost
tantra recovers at the butterfly mansion
and sees the cherry blossoms in bloom
alongside nezuko and nosuke and zenitsu
sleep peacefully at the other end of
tanzaro's bed when they arrive back at
the commodore household they find that
flowers are growing outside the house
and pay respect to the other commodores
by kneeling in front of the flowers and
praying they begin their new life
together at the commodore household
thank you guys so much for watching this
video it really means a lot to us we
will see you guys very soon in one of
our next videos